you are of course you've been doing
masters of sex now for several seasons
and it has got you're playing a famous
sex expert
this has got to filled your head with
amazing knowledge about sex you must now
be a sexual expert I'm laying this on
you
another thing I'm envious about but has
it you have you picked up some tips
absolutely none I just got the same old
tired moves that I use in real life
picked up nothing a touring sex a lot of
Port Talbot jokes that's a good one
that's a good one right there whatever
that was what was that good no I've
picked up absolutely nothing I was right
Wow tips wise yeah
picked up a few other things okay you
must clean that studio no yeah okay what
about this your friends watch the show
do you get comments from them about
because you have to be practically naked
in a lot of the show do your friends
ever comment on cuz you know you know
people yeah and they're friends of yours
and they watch the show do they ever
make comments well I have your nudity
yeah I have to say that I I was sort of
hoping that once I did a few sex scenes
on the show and I'd been naked that
people would kind of make jokes and it
would be all funny oh you know because
then you know that it's sort of
acceptable yeah the scary thing is when
no one says anything right it's the same
it's the same as this happened to me for
the first time the other day it's the
same as when you know when you make
jokes about your age or all I'm old man
now and people go no you're not don't be
ridiculous the day when you go I'm an
old man and people just go
you know your I know exactly what you're
talking about
all right oh let's change the subject
specifically like people you've known or
is you who well typically mention things
about your body where you think that's
weird don't talk about that my daughter
oh my god well yeah she took a turn I
wasn't excited and now this show will
never air no but my daughter you know
she she's 16 yeah it's it's not what
every sixteen-year-old once on their
Christmas list is I want my dad to be in
a show about sex yeah exactly doing
saying this worst nightmare yeah and so
she's not particularly happy about that
but she does mention that every now and
again she googles Michael Sheen naked
why on earth no don't embarrass me just
don't embarrass me she just does that I
think it's it's a way of her being able
to deal with it if you can see what's
out there then she's all right see
that's where I'm safe because if you
google Conan O'Brien naked nothing comes
up I have never been naked not only on
television anywhere in my personal life
coincidentally bizarrely if you do
Google Michael Sheen naked it Conan
O'Brien and Michael Sheen they could
come hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please